supongamos que tengo dos
transformaciones lineales la primera se
llama ese iba de r n
r m y la segunda transformación se llama
t y también va de rn
r m perfecto ahora lo que voy a hacer es
definir dos nuevas transformaciones a
partir de ese y de t así que esto es una
definición definición y es la
transformación s más te noten que todo
eso es una sola transformación ese
máster y ese máster aplicada a un vector
x simplemente es lo mismo que aplicar la
s al vector x y al resultado sumarlo con
t aplicada al vector x esto es lo que
hace la transformación
ahora bien noten que s manda un vector
en rn a un vector nrm así que esto está
en rm y te hace lo mismo así que esto
también está en r m como x estaba en rn
entonces puedo decir que
ese máster
es una transformación que va de rm
r m perfecto también voy a definir la
transformación de nuevo esto es una
definición
donde se es un escalar por la
transformación s y está aplicada a un
vector x lo que va a hacer es
simplemente tomar el escalar ce y
multiplicarlo por s de x de nuevo ese de
x está en rm así que hace por s de x es
un miembro de rm así que también sé por
s
la transformación se por s va de rm
r m perfecto bien pues como existe son
transformaciones lineales las puedo
representar mediante matrices
es decir
s x
s aplicada al vector x va a ser lo mismo
que alguna matriz a por el vector x cómo
se va de rn a rm entonces la matriz a
tiene que ser de dimensiones m por n
y esto lo puede hacer para cualquier
transformación lineal eso es un hecho
que ya hemos mencionado antes y hago lo
mismo para ti así que puedo decir que te
de equis o aplicada al vector x va a ser
lo mismo que la matriz b que de nuevo
como la transformación va de rm a rm va
a tener dimensiones m por n y la voy a
multiplicar por el vector x muy bien
ahora si conozco a ive que representan a
ese yate respectivamente que puede decir
acerca de las matrices que representan a
ese master y hace por ese pues vamos a
empezar con ese máster
la transformación ese máster aplicada a
un vector x quien es pues sencillamente
es ese aplicado a x que me da un vector
en rm más de aplicado a x que me da otro
vector nrm y lo sumo perfecto pues esto
por esta parte de aquí es lo mismo que
si digo sbx pues es lo mismo que la
matriz a por el vector x
y tdx es lo mismo que la matriz b por el
vector x así que puedes decir algo
acerca de la matriz que representa a ese
master bien pues antes que nada vamos a
decir que la matriz a voy a escribir
como siempre escribo las matrices
deberían estar un poco acostumbrados a
esto es la matriz que tiene por vectores
columna a1 a2 y tiene n columnas así que
así se sigue hasta a n
ahora bien la matriz a sm por en
entradas así que cada uno de estos
vectores a 1 a 2 y hasta n tienen m
entradas son miembros de rm la matriz de
la matriz b la voy a escribir como
v 1
v 2
hasta
hasta bn
muy bien y de nuevo también la matriz be
tiene columnas que tienen m entradas así
que estos también son vectores en rm
perfecto ahora el vector x vector x en
donde está pues pertenece al dominio
pertenece a rn entonces el vector x lo
puede escribir como
x 1 x 2 hasta x n
es una lista de n escalares ahora bien
consideremos el producto de la matriz a
por el vector x en el producto de la
matriz a por el vector x ya lo he dicho
mil veces sería x1 por el vector a 1 +
x2 por el vector a 2 más x 3 por el
vector a 3
así hasta x n por el vector n así que
vamos a anotar primero todo eso vamos a
fijarnos en este término en el vector en
la matriz a por el vector x eso me daría
como decía x 1 que es un escalar por a 1
que es un vector en r m + x2 que de
nuevo es una escalar por el vector a 2
que de nuevo está en r m y así voy a
continuar
hasta que llegue a xl de nuevo es un
escalar por el vector
m bien este es el primer término vamos a
ponerlo entre paréntesis
a eso le tengo que sumar los términos
que corresponden a la matriz b por el
vector x pero esos términos quienes son
pues son x1 por b 1 x 1 por b 1 + x2 x b
2 que de nuevo de 1 y b2 son vectores
nrm x1x dado son escalares y así me sigo
hasta x n por el vector de n
bien ahora como yo sé que los vectores
por escalares tienen la propiedad
distributiva el producto de escalares
por vectores tiene la propia
distributiva puedo reacomodar esto y
escribirlo como x1 por el vector a uno
más el vector b uno lo único que estoy
haciendo es sumando este término con
este término y factor izando x1 + x2
ahora asumo este con esto y factor hizo
x 2 x 2 por el vector a 2 más el vector
b 2
y así me sigo así me sigo hasta que
llegó al término xm por el vector a m
más el vector d
y esto esto lo puedo pensar del
siguiente modo podría pensar en una
nueva matriz de una nueva matriz cuyas
columnas van a ser precisamente estos
vectores a uno más b uno a dos más b 2
así hasta n más bm es decir la primera
columna es a uno el vector a uno más el
vector b uno
porque me pongo una línea aquí para que
distingamos la segunda columna es a dos
dedos
y así
y así hasta
que llegó a la columna m más de m
y toda esa matriz toda esa matriz la voy
a multiplicar por 100 pues por el vector
x x 1 x 2
hasta x n
y esta expresión es equivalente a este
producto de matrices que me pongo una
línea aquí no vayan a
confundirse pero entonces está muy padre
porque a partir de la definición que di
para la suma de transformaciones a
partir de la definición que me dice ese
máster aplicado x es ese de x + tx
concluyó que está mal esta
transformación debe ser representada por
una matriz que se obtiene al sumar las
columnas los vectores columnas
correspondientes de las matrices que
representan a ese y que representan a t
muy bien y entonces quizás ustedes estén
preguntando por qué me tomé la molestia
de hacer todo esto pues resulta que a
partir de esta matriz puedo hacer la
siguiente definición que hará que todo
sea bonito por así decirlo así que voy a
definir nuevo esto es una definición
a la suma de las matrices a ive
como la matriz
la matriz que es esto precisamente
simplemente es la matriz que obtengo si
sumo sus vectores columnas la primera
columna sería uno más b uno y así como a
caa2 más b 2
así hasta
m
más
y esto esto es algo agradable porque
entonces a partir de a partir de la
definición que di para la suma de
transformaciones cuando dije que ese
máster aplicado a x era lo mismo que ese
de x + tx
nosotros vimos que esto era lo mismo que
la matriz a por el vector x más la
matriz b por el vector x y a partir de
desarrollar todas estas definiciones y
simplemente a partir de la distribución
de los productos escalares con vectores
entonces
entonces concluí que esto era lo mismo
que a más ve a la matriz a más ve por el
vector x donde la matriz a más b está
definida de este modo así que es algo
bonito porque nos dice que la suma de
transformaciones es representada por la
suma de las matrices correspondientes
bien ahora qué pasa con el producto de
una escalarse por una transformación s
con la transformación c por s
bien pues la transformación se parece
transformación sé por ese la definía así
una escala hace por la transformación s
aplicado al vector x tiene y va a ser
pues si va a ser sencillamente c
c por s de x y esto
c por s x vamos a ponerlo entre
paréntesis yo sé que esto de aquí lo que
está dentro del paréntesis sbx es lo
mismo que la matriz a por el vector x
así que esto es lo mismo que el escalar
se por
por equis ahora bien quién es esto
quienes estoy aquí pues esto de aquí es
que no lo escribo un poquito aquí abajo
esto va a hacerse por a por equis pero a
por equis a lo calculamos arriba y es x
1 por el vector a 1 más x 2 por el
vector a 2 y así
así continuó hasta x n por el vector a n
perfecto ahora sí yo aquí si yo aquí
distribuyó la cee a lo largo de toda
esta suma porque recuerden la se
multiplica toda esta suma y la
intercambio con x1 porque las dos son
escalares y con x2 porque los dos son
escalares puede escribir todo esto como
x1 por c por a uno más x2 x c por a 2
recuerden a 1 2 a 2 y así hasta a n son
vectores así que más x cn por c por el
vector a n
ahora bien esto aquí es una nueva matriz
es una nueva matriz que matriz es bueno
más bien es el esto de aquí es el
producto de una nueva matriz con el
vector x esto es lo mismo que se
considera la matriz que tiene por
columnas a c por a uno separados y así
hasta port ainé es decir la matriz c por
a uno luego otra columna separados
otra columna separa tres y así hasta
hasta c por a n
y todo esto todo esto multiplicado por
el vector x que es el vector el vector x
1 x 2 hasta
hasta x n
perfecto y de nuevo que matrices está
pues esta matriz representa a la
transformación se por ese así que sería
bueno que fuera una matriz con un nombre
definido y lo que voy a hacer es definir
la voy a definir de nuevo esta es una
definición
la matriz sep ahora donde se es un
escalar como sencillamente el resultado
de multiplicar todas las columnas de a
por el escalar c así que es la matriz de
x a 1 separados hasta
sepor a n y en efecto esto significa
multiplicar todas las entradas de la
matriz a por c y de nuevo esto es algo
bonito porque ahora resulta que la
matriz que representa a la
transformación se por s es sencillamente
la matriz se x a donde a representa a la
transformación s bueno quizás están
preguntando oye yo ya en mi clase de
álgebra ya había aprendido cómo
multiplicar matrices por escalar es como
sumar matrices de la misma dimensión
como acá arriba entonces para que para
que te tomaste toda la molestia de
definir la suma de transformaciones o el
escalar por una transformación para que
lo hiciste pues la idea es que las
matrices se suman de un modo y se
multiplican por escalares de un modo
precisamente porque todo eso da
propiedades bonitas y todas esas
propiedades se conectan con el mundo de
las transformaciones así que si ustedes
empiezan desde las transformaciones
lineales pueden recuperar todas estas
propiedades bonitas que tienen la suma
de matrices
y la multiplicación de matrices por
escalares en el próximo vídeo voy a
hacer ejemplos donde multiplique
matrices por escalares y sume las
matrices para repasar un poco